let's get some perspective on this and
other stories and for that we turn to
CBS news political contributor Leslie
Sanchez Leslie good morning good morning
we just we just we're in this hyper
partisan adversarial environment
politically of course and we heard the
president say we must unify the nation
but at the same time asked if he would
tone it down he said he might tone it up
right how do we make any progress here
you know to do that it really requires a
self-examination of just how harsh the
rhetoric is and that's just a connection
that the president refuses to make and
until he said he acknowledges some
degree of culpability or accountability
within our tribe I would say the
Republican tribe then it's going to be
very difficult to discount any type of
fairness in this argument and that's as
we approach the midterms here it's not
likely he's going to do that because
he's trying to get his base fired up you
know the challenge with this is you used
to say that people bit their tongues
especially on the right and now they're
just completely silent when it comes to
something like this because the
president wins because the tactics tend
to mobilize activate a very disconcerted
base I meant a lot of non-traditional
voters who've come out for the first
time who feel the President may have
sharp elbows be very unorthodox but he
speaks his mind and they respect that
and they and more importantly I think
they respond to that and they turnout in
the poll might Democrats respond though
also in the idea that this has been
going on and there was so much anger on
both sides about these issues right a
reasonable minds would agree and I would
say suburban women particularly who are
watching this election or agreeing that
the tone needs to come down there needs
to be leadership on this but we've yet
to see that there's that out there at
the polls in our presidential leadership
but the question is who's going to fill
that void because somebody ultimately
will so we've been hearing for the past
couple of weeks about this care of the
caravan of migrants coming up that's
immigration border security long before
they would actually reach here
what are Democrats and Republicans for
that matter seeing in terms of the rally
of their base on core subjects like
immigration border security and on the
Democrat side about the you know the
economy about health care those key
issues right well other Republicans
recognize
that immigration is one of those areas
that it's frenzied up and activated
abase some of that is based on native
his fears some of that is the distrust
of the Congress and the Republican
Congress particularly to do anything on
border enforcement because they harken
back to Ronald Reagan 1986 are going to
give amnesty to all these Central
Americans and they don't even want to
talk about the 12 million plus that are
undocumented living in the United States
right now so there's all of these
problems with a failed immigration
system but you can rally on kind of
these immigration talking points that
get the base really motivated that's a
very dangerous area but it has but it
has benefited the president obviously in
his in his last moments a couple of
weeks before their midterms there's a
battle to sort of raise voter enthusiasm
on both sides any sense of who has the
edge they're really interesting there I
would say the Democrats on paper have
done an extremely important job of
activating young voters non-traditional
voters those working-class Democrats to
come out and they've actually balanced
out with Republican gains that we saw in
2014 2016 question is it's really
mano-a-mano down to those individual
congressional districts and it's just
all bets are off right now it all comes
down to the election ten days away as
you said we thank you so much likely
Sanchez